we've got a little game for you that we
want to play called my first time what
was the first movie you ever saw in the
theater hundred and one down nation we
were really young and my friend's mother
took us my first time you know going
into a theater I was hooked on the first
time you know just being there and and
the whole experience and you know I'm
popcorn that big-screen you know it was
just like an event and so I was just a
movie being ever since what was the
first r-rated movie you ever saw it was
a movie called the Mac and a movie
called coffee
starring Pam Grier and it was like raw
you know I'm saying you know these
movies were hardcore and it was exciting
you know and I loved him you know I
remember going home and saying all the
words and getting in trouble he's no
because I was reacting the movie out but
you know it really turned me on to what
movies could be who was the first person
that you would say really inspired you
Jim Brown and uh Jim Kelly and Fred
Williamson you know those dudes are like
old school you know a lot of them played
and a lot of blaxploitation movies they
really really show you know how cool a
black man could be who was the first
person who believed in you as an actor
John Singleton he had this movie he was
doing called boys in the hood he was
like man you'd be perfect for it and so
he knew how to be an actor before I know
tell me about your first time writing a
screenplay John Singleton once again he
said maybe you can write records and do
music that vividly I know you can write
a movie I started writing my first
script but maybe 1990 and it's sucked
but I kept working at it and my third
script was Friday which I wrote with a
DJ poop and that ended up being a
classic so you know I got better and
then just seeing the whole journey of
your career and then having your son
coming okay I want to act was the first
piece of advice you gave him about
acting do the work required to become a
great
you know use your talent so he's gonna
be pretty good and I was a parent that's
all you really care about is that your
kids step up at the moment of truth and
he did and we proud of them I can't wait
to to be on the screen with him one day
all the new dealers in Atlanta are
getting supplied through Antonio Pope in
Miami you need to get me something on
this guy two days tops we're gonna team
together and fix this put me in on it
James I'm like half cop half Puma I'm
getting you ass